Christian Bale let's war could so get
under Thor's skin guys I think Christian
Bale is gonna be Silver Surfer
Christian Bale has had all these body
types baby great bb8 and he'll grow the
board Molina I wear baby shirts
according to yeah actually we're calling
out is what's the Dark Knight doing in
the for movie Christian Bale is gonna be
in Thor movie and we're gonna have some
robe theories about why and who speaking
of who with me is Erik Bosse oh yeah
Tommy Bechtold hello and marina Mastro's
do you have anything to say to me I'm
sorry it's really hard to find thunder
shirt for me any us on this episode
we're going to do rise the real reason
that in universe real reason that Kevin
Feige changed the one division release
date that but we're gonna explain why he
did that and maybe so this week that
Christian Bale is in talks to play a
role in Thor 11 Thunder tycho at Edie's
follow up to Thor Ragnarok
he's a major star already obviously he's
played one of the most iconic super
heroes of all time Patrick Bateman yeah
but movies but that's such a huge actor
to be bringing in to to just you know
the third or fourth Thor movie and
historically when DC actors do Marvel
movies it doesn't work out Deadpool
being a great example he was amazing as
Green Lantern and then Deadpool yeah
yeah so this is a huge actor one of the
biggest actors to bring in at this stage
and franchise so it's got to be a
significant role I'm gonna take a
character off the table though
and that's beta ray bill because even
though everyone is room reknit to be
that character I'm just gonna throw out
there Christian Bale is too big an actor
to get a weird horse face thing put on
under a chance he could work out and get
it yeah I did recently but so that
character is really fun and interesting
and a robot who's as worthy as Thor kind
of a really ridiculous character but
listen let's say not not that character
because I think we're gonna see this
guy's face okay so who do we go
what better face to bring into a Thor
movie than that of gore the god butcher
okay so when tyka announced that they
were gonna do this movie at comic-con
last summer they talked about who's
gonna adapt
Jason Aaron's the Mighty Thor series
which features Jane Foster picking up
Neil near but leading up to the Mighty
Thor series was the original sin series
and that's the one that followed gore
the god butcher who is this like serial
killer who hates all deities in the
Marvel Universe because he lost his
family on this desolate homeworld he
prayed to the deities to Odin to help
him out and they got murdered so now
he's pissed and he carries this this
necro sword he's a badass and he goes
after Thor and his ideas to depower Thor
and there's a moment where later in the
comics Nick Fury whispers something into
Thor's ear and we don't find out what it
is and Thor just drops the hammer and
walks away from being the god Thunder
and later we find out the thing that
fury whispered in his ear was gore was
right and that Thor is not worthy no
one's worthy of being a god
so so then Thor word leaves me only er
behind and who picks it up later is Jane
Foster and in this other storyline so I
think what we're gonna see is Christian
Bale as gore the god butcher one of the
craziest badass God killers in the Thor
conics and he like
he's gonna follow in the footsteps of
Kate Blanchet who is another great
doctor who I never would have thought
would be in a Marvel movie let alone a
goofy cosmic Taika Waititi Thor movie
and I think when Dale saw Kate Blanchet
do that he's like oh I could do this too
yeah yeah but hopefully they'll give him
better hair because they did her dirty
with that yeah I really like the idea of
somebody who can take down gods I think
that that is you know one of my favorite
things so they obviously sample a lot
from Greek stories and and yes Greek
mythos and the idea of a normal man
being able to take down the God or being
even comparable to a God
I mean Odysseus is an example of that
but somebody who's as wise a Prometheus
in a trick the guy right yeah and so
that's always except a fascinating role
to play in there and I love when Thor
acknowledges they you know obviously
it's more Smith's with them but
acknowledges like we're gods and we kind
of just play around with that but we
don't really acknowledge like what that
means that literally in the world where
there are superheroes we're still above
those characters even we're freaking
gods so a character that specifically
goes off to after that title is really
yesterday and if we're gonna have
Natalie Portman come back as Jane Foster
this sets up all that like gore
Christian Bale as gore could so get
under Thor's skin that that's what
forces him to lead in this case it would
be Stormbreaker behind but it seems like
it the comic-con panel is me linear
which is weird cuz that's been shattered
places we're in an alternate universe or
something which we could be yeah
tell me you you said that it would be
more interesting as Al Gore the god
butcher yes I'll tell you an
inconvenient truth you've led Asgard
burn yeah why the climate changes what
brought down a scarred isn't it if we
really think about it yeah I was
thinking he's also like that Houser is
like eight octaves higher
okay the dog that talks to homer or
something follow five your soulmate
homer anybody have any reasons why
Erik's wrong is wrong I just have a
better of Christian Bale's character
endure Gundam yes so I think it's a
family affair you know I think we're
going to see we're gonna see where we
left Asgard off its new Asgard now
somewhere in what like Canada or
something like that and as eons bird
Norway no that's what I met Norway where
did they film frozen so so Valkyries in
charge Thor has stepped away but I think
there's gonna start to be some beacons
in the universe because we got to take
this thing back to space and what we're
gonna see is some ancient as Guardians
who have been cast out by Odin or by
other forces throughout time or have
left under their own volition are gonna
start to reconvene to build a new new
Asgard up in space and what we're gonna
have there then is going to be a
summoning and the Asgardians and new
Asgard are gonna be like alright we got
to go back bled by Valkyrie and once
they're all together it's gonna be a bit
of a power struggle Game of Thrones
situation with different people laying
claim to the front of Asgard
enter Culberson brother alone in I love
this already and he steps in as a bit of
a like at first an advisory a friendly
role like let me help you look kind of a
little finger almost like a very smooth
like I've been here before I know all
these players I know the bureaucracy I
know how to establish a new Kingdom but
what we don't realize is Coe Boursin who
in the comics is kind of a bit of a
beige blank canvas it's not really cold
Boursin at all everyone what it's a back
door it's Owen Reese molecule man who as
we know is actually just a form of
Beyonder so this is an introduction to a
massive Marvel villain who for
three-quarters of the movie we think is
called Morrison but it actually don't
think is a vanilla character by the god
of fear when you're not afraid of
anything he doesn't bother I'm 36
with a huge electricity bill anyway no
but I think course exam vanilla but he's
definitely a character that no one's
gonna be like I needed to see him
through three movies but sure as a
conduit to introduce a huge massive
villain I think you could have him just
really choose actor of Christian Bale's
character chewing the scenery as this
advisor seemingly without an agenda
father figure to Valkyrie and also we're
gonna have Jane Foster and there's so
much so presumably they're going to team
up or maybe he's maybe he's manipulating
Thor against Valkyrie or something like
that you know what I mean maybe he's
establishing seeds of doubt and then to
reveal this massive kind of manipulator
that then the Beyonder is through
molecule man who is another huge villain
but they're all you know they're kind of
all interconnected because they're
basically one entity but Owen Reese gets
part of Beyonder and becomes molecule
man who's one of the more powerful
villains in the Marvel Cinematic world
we're not cinematic but Marvel comic
universe right now so I think it's just
a great way to introduce a massive movie
star for three more movies yeah I get
that I think that I'm into the reason I
was so into the cull part is you know
you see you mentioned Game of Thrones
actually and it is very similar to you
can think of call kind of as
what's-his-face with the ships oh the
yeah that you're on Greyjoy where you're
Chris gray where your uncle is you know
the threat to your throne right so this
is Thor's uncle call who is as powerful
as his dad and as every boy knows your
dad is the strongest person alive so
this character has Odin level powers
that being a challenge to Valkyrie or
Thor or divers like imagine you know
Thor fighting Odin and that's something
we kind of get to see with Cole but I do
agree that that sounds like it would
last about a movie mhm and then we'd be
like Great God versus God fight which is
really interesting well we've had in the
previous Lord hella right yeah right so
I do see how that could kind of like
Peter out I do I'm gonna give you a
Rogie real quick because I'm still on
this first thing also throw
there there's a the idea that call
creates kind of dark Asgard and in in
Antarctica in the comics that is really
fascinating because leave a legion of
dark as Guardians versus as Guardians
and now we have a civil war with an
Asgardian that's really interesting to
me and then you made it to beyond her
thing until for that you get a little
beyond bonus quarter okey yeah Eric
doesn't know he's pregnant everything's
happening for us blames the big ass do
not do no one is we do all have guys I
think Christian Bale is gonna be Silver
Surfer oh okay yes and along
Tommy's lines he's there he's gonna
introduce Faison basically is there to
connect to a bigger what are you doing I
was laughing cause he forgot Tom he's
doing in per second because who would be
a long Tommy's lines the introduction of
a much bigger like bad
Silver Surfer is server is gonna connect
us to Galactus yes okay so also
Christian Bale is known for like
changing his body right for role and
Silver Surfer is like this long lanky
like very thin dude if you compare him
to the twins from the shining
triple hi Christian Bale has had all
these body types baby Groot bb-8 and
he'll grow the board like just as if
Christian Bale doesn't want to have this
man doesn't already have it or doesn't
already have it right okay so no that's
that's from our Halloween episode and in
the beginning of the movie we might even
see him as before him in his human form
before he becomes Silver Surfer right um
so we might get to see his origin
because Christian Bale wants to I mean
he's a huge star he wants to be a
well-rounded character but he also
doesn't really want to be in a ton of
superhero movies as we know because he's
not who he already did that so but I can
see him you know like wanting to do this
one and done and then he introduces you
know Silver Surfer is The Herald of
Galactus so we gets introduced he brings
about this is him doing it he brings
about Galactus by the end of the movie
he's done he's made a bajillion dollars
and he can go back to his mansion but
having done some nice art with Natalie
Portman and played a really good
interesting Silver Surfer and then we're
off to the races with Galactus line of
like Silver Surfer he's got a very like
I'm digging the Patrick Bateman like
he'll what do you do that like just
sprayed with silver I I mean I
definitely am into this authoritative
version of Christian Bale I think he
could pull that off it was a Morpheus
voice right in the previous Duck Jones
body yeah remember we saw I saw Laurence
Fishburne in a garage working on it
Laurence Fishburne's house yeah yeah
yeah it was his work his home slash
office anyway so so I'm super into the
idea of bringing in Silver Surfer I
don't love the idea of and then
immediately getting rid of it but he
does like money so you have the
potential to grow this yes if you show
it love okay give back to me in a tweet
also based on how successful your tweet
is Thor for a Gore war yeah
want some more Norris and more okay
great
Thoris no more it's a Jane gang now but
we're much fonder of the Beyonder yeah
yeah yeah light applause preparation for
Galactus murder Christian Bale is Silver
Surfer I think it's the Silver Rose in
30 days I'm really terrible at those so
yeah it is very good give it up
everybody yeah let's take a quick break
hey guys Eric here in new rockstars
newest show that we're really excited
for you to check out is the big question
each week we tackle one of the biggest
nerd questions and apply science numbers
and awkward logic to it
like when will baby Yoda hit puberty how
many people does the Hulk kill when he
claps - excitedly who did Palpatine bang
all these Plus will answers shorter
questions that you can submit to us
better personal lives or just nagging
questions you had after Watchmen or
Witcher Westworld or whatever w-whoa
whoa wha whoa goblin it's also one of
the funniest shows we've made
let's get boozed up we let our editors
make fun of us if you haven't watched
definitely check it out I think you'll
love it again it's called the big
question you can watch it
YouTube or get audio versions on the
podcast channel the big question
wherever you get you podcasts guys there
is another kind of smaller MCU news that
where I want to dive into but it
actually has potentially a bigger impact
on the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's because over the holidays it came
out that they're going to move Wan
division up sooner like a lot it was
gonna come out in 2021 now somehow it's
gonna come out in 2020
which seems like crazy it doesn't mean
that they shot it really yeah because
it's such a big expensive project
they're spending as much money on these
things as we watch our shows so this is
a huge strategic move for Kevin Feige I
want to know why why did he make this
decision in universe what does he need
out of it in the MCU well I think this
is a good sign for one division I think
I feel like he Kevin Feige must feel
bullish on one division right in order
to move it earlier yeah we've kind of
talked about how this theory that James
Gunn getting fired screwed up all of
their plans for phase 4 and it forced
Kevin Feige into a position where he
wanted to lead with guardians 3 is the
kickoff movie of phase 4 but because it
had to be rescheduled and forced him out
to lead with things like the Black Widow
movie things like Falcon Winter Soldier
which look really cool and interesting
but they're kind of like espionage
stories that don't really have like
multiverse implications on the surface
so I think he's getting returns he's
seen episode early cuts of whan division
and he's thinking to himself this show
could be my introduction to the
multiverse that I've been dreaming of he
kind of hinted this at Brazil's
comic-con in December like we're now
shooting two shows both of which are
gonna be multiverse connected I think
he's really excited to introduce the
Marvel multiverse the marvel cinematic
multiverse to the world and I think
Wanda vision could be a show so right
now all the art shows like Dick Van Dyke
sitcom suburbia 1950 suburbia what if
each episode of Wanda vision is like a
totally different genre and that
suburbia is just episode 1 episode 2 is
like a crime
or like it's taking place yeah yeah it's
just like community yeah and it could be
each is its own kind of like parity
universe and that sets up the idea of
all the different shades of the Marvel
multiverse so we can explore these
different base for films you have like a
horror film with multiverse of madness
you have another like cosmic rom-com
with Thor 11 Thunder you have blade
coming up which is like supernatural
horror sometime and Beyond 2021 so yeah
I think he's gonna use Wanda vision as
kind of like the road map for how we're
gonna be able to look at face forward
and he wants to bring it up earlier in
the calendar so that that can kind of be
his kick off face for what are the
implications of bringing it earlier
having a multiverse start earlier by
letting this be the kickoff to phase
four it's a multiverse story as opposed
to a mid-2000 spy movie set a story yeah
all of phase 4 and if like the
introduction to phase 4 is about this
character who's dead you know Natasha
Romanoff and it just eats by movie but
it doesn't really set up universe
implications as much it kind of feels
like if you were to lead phase 3 with
the Winter Soldier you know which is a
great film's awesome one of my favorite
MCU films but it doesn't really set up
the universe as well as the first
Avengers movie or like Civil War or like
Doctor Strange or guardians of the
galaxy you can see how other movies
could tie in with those so by moving one
division earlier in the schedule you
have a story that's set in the
multiverse and by having each episode
set in a different reality of that
multiverse you could start to see how
each of these different movies in the
phase four and phase five lineups could
be set in each of those different
realities yeah I see that you're so
you're like drawing the lines where if
Ironman when that came out was to
establish this idea that there is a
world very similar to ours where people
you know do a heroic and then super
heroic things and then Avengers is like
and by the way aliens are real mm-hmm
and space is actually a place we're
gonna play in and you're saying that
level of shift is about to happen with
one division this would be and other
universes are also part of our
playground yeah I think before this
strategy
was Oh Wanda vision will set up dr.
strange in the multiverse of madness
they'll kind of be companion pieces but
now I think Kevin Feige as we're in the
middle of this gap period he's feeling
itchy and he's worried that Marvel fans
are losing sense of what the multiverse
is and now he's seen like returns from
like as they're producing Wanda vision
he's like oh this could be the way I
explained to the world what the
multiverse is and I don't want to wait
till spring 2021 I want to do it before
some of these other things come out I
like it one Rogi an excellent point
there I think the fact that like there's
a little bit of like we can't just keep
saying this has to happen soon because
there's just so much competitive content
but this is more the creative discussion
so for me I think it's because the two
shows the reason they moved for Wanda
vision closer is because the two shells
are can be way more intertwined both the
outcome in her soul yes we're talking
about it then we know because I mean
just by looking at the art and like the
you know the promotional stills we've
seen they couldn't seem like two more
different television shows right like
Wanda vision were looks like this kind
of high art like abstract concept where
we're kind of unsure first of all cuz
vision is dead in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right now and so it's like is
Wanda imagining him is this a healing
thing for her where she's created this
kind of like external world where she
can go off to and like live with him and
be happy you know kind of similar to
like I mean we see this in Marvel all
the time with the way like what was it
Tahiti is like the place where they go
to heal and it's all like it the brands
and stuff you know is this just her
version of that that she can manifest
with her powers or is there a larger
again nefarious being that has them
trapped in a there has her trapped in
his using vision to kind of torture her
but she doesn't realize it so she's
living out in these day-to-day fantasy
worlds kind of tying in with yours Eric
where it's a different different genre
each time and she doesn't really realize
she's in you know there's a lot of great
psychological fantasy movies where
people don't realize that you know yeah
a prison of their own minds and so this
could be the next verse yeah yeah like
the cell or even what was that Cusack
movie 13th
14:08 or identity identity when i'm
thinking about but yes but where he is
fine where he's all the people yeah
anyway but and then i think that the
tie-in will be that there's gonna start
to be rips in the fabric in the Winter
Soldier in Falcon and they're gonna
realize they have to rescue Wanda that's
where the two shells will converge at
the end and then I think the probably
like the penultimate episode will be a
direct slingshot into the movies I think
because Disney Plus is a little more
prestigious than than ABC television you
know what I mean like so like where as
agents of shield is such a great
companion show and really did kind of
amazing things for a network television
show
I think they don't let it all hang out
with Disney Plus shows I think they're
gonna be very closely tied to the movies
you don't even like I don't think
they're gonna be like we can only have
these huge actors in these shows for few
moments obviously the stars of the
movies yeah so I think it's gonna be a
much I think the reason they had to move
wand division up is because it's too
much information transfers between both
shows and if you watch them years apart
from each other
you'll look forget you yeah and people
this stage don't seem to be willing to
put that effort in people it's out of
sight out of mind it is interesting that
you bring up agents of shield because
agents of shield tried to be that
connective tissue between the movies and
it would kind of set up the next movie
and there's a threat that we're seeing
and coming but no one was really
watching it and they would never allow
to even like say everyone's names they
were talking about the big guy yeah
exactly so I do I do like that this is
another attempt at that but here's what
I mostly like about it is what did the
MCU do they that was just a brilliant
move that everyone I was like yeah it's
a no brainer is the post credit scene
leaving every single movie on a
cliffhanger of course they'll do that
with the shows to write each one is
gonna like just leave you all I need to
see the next one
Tommy I love it let's give you a silver
road it's worth just to rope what to do
but he will rub it in a little different
loses corner okey
[Applause]
we got great I think they moved up Wanda
vision specifically to tie in with the
New Mutants movie which actually got
this idea from Eric because if you guys
watch Eric's video of the breakdown of
the trailer of New Mutants honestly you
just say it as kind of like not a
throwaway but like you say it at the end
is kind of just like a fan theory that
you just kind of throw out I don't
really know but yeah but let's like
watching that I really like grasped onto
it and especially narrative Li like as
Tommy was saying like we I don't think
Disney and fy'y trust audiences to wait
a year between things so it's like okay
New Mutants is coming out are we really
gonna wait a year to tie into everything
else in Disney into time mutants into
Disney like No so at the I think it's
gonna be what you just said is that if I
he's gonna make the director of New
Mutants put a post-credits scene in that
has one division that has the Scarlet
Witch in it and she's the only one cuz
it's a straight-up horror movie like
yeah um uses a straight-up horror movie
and does that like tie in directly with
the Disney like the way that Disney
movies look no but the way that you get
around that like you said is that Wanda
is that Scarlet Witch can see in two
different universes different dimensions
so chic she's the only one who can see
into this like horror dimension so she
sees it and she can pop back in and out
come back in you know if she wants to
make that a reality visit it bring
people back from it she can scoop those
people somehow that movie performs will
take you and bring them over age them
what five six years in 2016
yeah that also puts the stamp on it like
yeah this is a mutants movie but it's
and you're used to it not being Disney
but here but like being like it's Disney
we own it here it is and it doesn't have
to be overly like the movie gets to stay
the way that it is because it's already
made and
by moving up the show it's like oh great
they are actually connected we're not
just like telling you it's connected and
then making you wait a really long time
it's going know like we respect this
enough to move up the show to show you
that they really are connected and give
fans what they what they think they want
and you know people do have short
attention story wise I do like the idea
that they're doing it because they they
need to make New Mutants make sense yeah
because that is one of the biggest
questions is like great everything
settled you know they we told our Star
Fox version of the mutants story and
then it kind of came to an end they're
in a you know and then and then they
kind of were about to just do a nice
switch over and then they were like wait
what do we do about New Mutants yeah
both these announcements came within a
week of each other we found out that one
division was gonna be in 2020 and then
like a couple days later Josh Boone is
like actually New Mutants is coming in
to in April yeah I grew and then yeah
you know it's funny it's not going to
college anymore cuz it didn't knows
pregnant are you giving back to me this
week the but oh I got it
Wanda no more psyches vision is 20/20
yeah so great about me what was the your
theory the Falcon and soldier getting
bolder with Wanda joining the you can do
it party Wanda vision business decision
Disney goes broke with joke screening
let's see one division bumped to the
front of the MCU roll out because it
will be our vision to the future of
multi party joke why did I make it up to
rhyme now now we're all doing it one
division creates new debits because in
the New Mutants someone bring me to my
chamber my powers of guys let us know in
the comments if any of these made any
sense
and review those those tweets the sweet
part of it but real quick question guys
cats came out over the holidays it was
shredded apart by the critics give me
your best cat pun review headline know
the Jellicle on this studio still
release this trash this film should have
been cat nipped in the bud yeah there we
go one of these can be said without
censoring
Road question season 2 of the mineral
line is rumored to have some cameos from
the film's
what Star Wars characters would he like
to see cameo in a DeLorean season do
quick I want to see the guy with the ice
cream machine from Cloud City oh I want
to see the space diner owner from Attack
of the Clones
the guy with the handlebar moustache I
want to see the grown-up kids who are
like the Anakin's friends the podrace
all those answers are incorrect
incorrect answer was baboo Frick next
question
give me your best baboo freakin Pro so
[Applause]
[Applause]
another full stay all right great
guys that's it that is we just count
them up let's see who won this episode
of road theory Eric what do you got I
have two Rogie points
[Laughter]
3.2 and 2.5 oh wow boys so Tommy is our
winner
and just as we roll out everyone is
going to give Tommy a cool new nickname
and then I guess you can pick which one
you have to keep but that's it for this
episode of rogue theory thanks for going
rogue with us thanks so much to our
guest Eric Foss really say had nothing
to say yes I mean a mattress
but guys I'm on Twitter and Maria to
master and Tommy false allegations Beck
told weight loss camp come on where's he
going what's his nickname sidestepping
those allegations tickle me Tommy
okay it's not an invitation Tommy's
Tommy
Big Boss Beck told ya Tommy Beck told I
was just gonna make an accusation
Tommy Beck told didn't kill himself
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]